you were being considered for this role
but I do audition yeah for the role of
Pennywise and you decided is this right
that you were going to dress in the
clown makeup for the audition um not
entirely well so um the the audition
itself they were like hey here's I was
in LA and they were like do you want to
audition for Pennywise and that is not
you know an opportunity that you get
very often it's such an amazing
character to do and yeah you know
there's no real restrictions to whatever
you know what you can and cannot do so
you know you started incorporating
things that I wanted to incorporate like
the lip and and my weird eyes and all
these kind of things to kind of mold out
the character and I did my first
audition and it went really well and an
Andy the director you know wanted me for
a callback and was down to four people
and I guess two of the four that were
left had come in clown face for the
first audition mm-hmm
I had not so he wanted us who didn't
come in you know with the clown face on
to come with clown face and the ones who
did not so I and I didn't know really
what to do with that but I was like okay
I guess I you know okay get a little
clown makeup on my face and it's the
morning of and I get into my car and oh
yeah and so so andy director he asked me
like the day before he said can you
figure out maybe a laugh you know cuz
there wasn't really a laugh in the
scenes like we're gonna laugh I'm like
okay sure and I was just I was staying
at his house and those poor people in
the house and I felt sort of early
self-conscious about practicing sure so
but I get in the car and you know when
you're in the car you get into this like
safe bubble of being in your own car in
clown face and I'm like here it is and I
just started you know well out in the
car driving through Hollywood in clown
face
amania the strangest thing so and the
casting directors place it was the only
Street parking so I had to park the car
and go out and not you know walk two
minutes right to the thing in clown face
and there are usually regular clothes by
the way yeah and I was like okay so
there's two two things to go you know
there's two ways to go about this either
I become really self-conscious being
like sorry I think I'm gonna do them an
actor yeah I'm sorry or I sort of tried
to be in character yeah and I did the
latter so I just walked and I was like
[Laughter]
workers and walk around in Hollywood and
they sort of looked at me like not not
surprised at all yeah yeah because I
just saw like a spider-man with a fanny
pack right it's not your week morning
morning in the Hollywood
you